[Music]
welcome
what's up so far
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is Spin to Win I like spinning
I like winning I'm assuming that if I'm
going to spin the win I cannot hear
anything
then I'm gonna win
oh wait a minute no hang on I take back
everything I said wait I don't want to
spin
speakers busted lamps missing the bulb
there's a piss stain on the floor oh no
there's more piss in the photo oh
is that what it looks like outside what
are those huge monsters maybe it's a
painting why it's got to be a photo
I guess I spin
[Music]
okay
speakers busted well I don't know about
that don't know
it's broken why is everything gotta be
broken
why has everything gotta be broken so I
spin and I win a prize is that what I
get what do I get what do I get
oh I can't wait
[Music]
Sentinels
what oh cup noodle instant noodles I'm
so hungry I'll wait a few more spins to
see if I can get some hot water that's a
good idea I think I'm not sure why but
it seems like it might be a good idea
[Music]
wow
[Music]
roads Road Rose
looks like everything's oh a nice
decoration until we both die that's a
little pessimistic
it could be great it could be wonderful
it could be fantastic
it's probably gonna be
[Music]
what stick stick
I got a stick friend for the flower oh
hell yeah I love stick I love stick I
would not notice if there was like a
shadow person in the corner when I
turned around here sometime
there better not be a shadow person in
the corner around here sometime
[Music]
sand
oh oh it was a bit creepy when it came
down fun to play with more fun to eat I
tried eating some but it doesn't taste
oh no they know me oh no they know me
oh no
[Music]
all right what have you got
cat toy
oh oh
something to pass the time well I mean
oh it's fun for me too where'd it go
there it is meow meow uh well not that
fun for me I didn't mean to be so
literal because game seems to have a
have a read on me and I don't like that
[Music]
what months
but but but
butts bugs
thank God they're dead where did I put
them did I just where did I put them in
this word up
oh good
creepy but not so crawly all right well
that's something man I'm getting real
presentable Liberty Vibes out of this I
don't feel so good everybody
one box
oh I'm getting carved oh that's a great
box it's not small enough but it's still
a pretty decent box there that's all
right I'm over
hmm
[Music]
music Music Academy
foreign
I mean of all the things it's really not
that bad
really getting a lot of presentable
Liberty Vibes feeling like my Freedom's
not actually my own and I my agency of
self is being dissolved
sleeping bag oh
no more back pain this is great I'm not
tired of oil already fine
but anyway this is uh doing pretty good
you know I'm surprised
[Music]
companion companion come in companion
companion
what do you mean
what do you mean
what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean a companion what do you mean
what do you mean a companion what do you
mean is it in the room with me right now
is there a companion in here is that
what you said you said companion right
oh wait a minute
oh wait a minute
[Music]
foreign
poor guy must have gotten caught on
something
I'll keep it in case I need a hand with
it
oh take a seat oh good yup I'll get
Blood Stained if I sit on this
oh great great
great
[Music]
chalk chalk oh
oh no it's a scribble insane writing on
the wall how insane
how insane we talking oh that's not
nearly insane enough I can do way better
than that
I can do way better than that
hmm
very long
song Hood the hood of songs
chocolate I thought it was like a hood I
put over my head and it plays songs
life is like a boxing yeah okay
life is okay well not for that guy not
for the bugs
great
[Music]
what statue statue
I shouldn't stand under that oh oh oh oh
something worth winning I did it I did
it I did it I don't like it I hate it Hi
how are you don't talk to it
oh I don't like that
I don't like that
you stay there
ax
interesting
self-defense
I guess what an easy way out below the
one with the wheel will probably kill me
anyway yeah probably God I don't like
you I don't trust you I don't trust you
at all I'm losing my mind I'm losing my
mind in this game I'm losing my mind I'm
losing my mind
losing a bit of my mind
for the ax
oh whoa who's the shadowy nothingness I
took it it's mine
foreign
hey
hey
hey
hey
now don't do any of that
blindfold
blindfold light light bulb could have
fixed the lamp with that well
better than a blindfold to be honest I
could just close my eyes I guess
by up I up I'm up
I'm up
oh no wait a minute
wait
well I got it's not hot water but
I should put my prize somewhere first oh
I'm putting it oh I'm putting it oh I'm
putting it up oh I'm putting it oh I'm
putting it okay I'm putting it up
I'm
I'm
well
just goes to show gambling doesn't pay I
think that was the moral of this I think
there is a moral of this and I think we
all know what the moral is and I've said
it out loud whatever I said was what it
was so that's what it is thank you
vanon
welcome to map friend we
need to
look at Maps
which is always the best thing to do
great did you know click on a location
to go there exploring is fun with map
friend I just bet it is
I just bet it is
to go back to the map you click on me
yay
oh what a wonderful day
can I go anywhere else
okay
fun
this is delightful
this is stupendously good
wow
[Music]
something by the way this picture was
taken doesn't rub me the right way oh
did you know map then map friend finds
the best most up-to-date info about your
favorite locations Willow Forest I put
this relatively unknown Forest on number
five Willow force is actually really
beautiful in Spring it's not super big
but it's worth the Excursion especially
the views on West Water Lake are great
from here I go with my family every now
and then so be sure to let me know if
you're going Josh nature review at dot
bloggingnuck.com sure that's a real
website
you need explore orbs to fly to New
collocations this help keeps costs down
great explore orbs
explorbs
I got explorers everybody
I got explorbs oh I think I can drop
that wherever I don't have to ah
interesting
fascinating West Waterview westwater
view is a parking spot that provides
camping amenities to visitors of Lake
westwater camping amenities are limited
but the day fee is very cheap at just
three dollars a day
thanks did I get any orbs about that
no no warbs
no no norbs no norbs
right
okay
well this is unsettling
I don't remember if Google Maps always
had to render the entire Earth as you
were exploring it probably doesn't bode
well about Google being the over mind
controlling all of us but whatever
Willow Beach is located on the shores of
Lake westwater the closest town is
westwater Township as of the 2004 census
population was 567 contained 280 housing
units the town is most known for the
infamous Petersburg airsprip where the
no
hey you found another explorb
thanks you can fly anywhere you want to
so am I crazy in that there was not an
Explorer here
no Explorer
[Music]
oh I can move
[Music]
I wasn't able to do that before
I don't know if there's a point to this
or if I'm going to wander into something
horrible but I am exploring uh so I had
to have this pointed out to me there's
something over here I don't I don't I
don't know why
[Music]
I never thought to go out in the middle
of the ocean hi
oh no info on this location maybe
something's wrong I think it's not where
you're looking for some where else
wow well at least I have enough explores
[Music]
can't wait to see where I go next
[Music]
that's not what I was saying what is DZ
anyway
oh where are we flying to now did you
know no I didn't know
I didn't know it all
I have no idea
I'm gonna see what's over here
wow endless desert I'm so thrilled the
ghoul
it was a pleasure flying with you was
was was
what do you mean was what do you mean
were
hello
what no no no no no no no
the n6 runs between North Africa
bordered by the Mediterranean Sea in the
north and West Africa bordered by the
high cost of Paving you seem to be in an
area with not a lot of data are you sure
you're looking right
I don't know
I have we'll come back here explorb
I found another Explorer but I can't
wait to see what this mystery flesh pit
ass thing is
what are you
[Music]
yup ah
oh it's nothing
turns out it was nothing all along
there I was thinking that it was
something and I was like oh wait no I'm
an idiot it was nothing at all man how
could I forget that it was nothing at
all anyway
according to Western nothing
according to nothing according to
absolutely no one and don't ask me again
and get out of my house
ah come back here
great
can't wait to get another new location
I'm having so much fun
[Music]
oh I gotta do a thing
that's oddly specific
I did not know that I knew that in my
head but I do oh
the Crosswinds were steady at 20 knots
now it's 30 knots
do you you couldn't have known captain
what what
the heck
[Music]
oh
well
ain't this um
that's uh
that's a something
oh okay all right
[Music]
oh what did I see what did I see I
didn't know what I saw what did I saw oh
whatever I saw Lexi and will enhance it
enhance it looks in
whatever that was that was amazing and
or horrifying horror film Amazing great
moving on
welcome to the ball pit
at McDonald's
great can't wait to go into the ball pit
wow boy I am very hungry that blood it
might not be blood but I don't think the
alternative is any better uh hello all
right great
hey wow oh God I'm glad I just grabbed
that off the counter hey what's up now
can I have all your money and a brown
cow I'm gonna go into the bullpen now oh
God blow up this
all right I'm gonna go in the play no
I'm not
I want to go in the ball pit oh I gotta
hit the actual door handle which makes
sense if you think about it
damn I'll need to find a way to turn the
lights on why is this my job
also who
I don't know what that is and I don't
want to know what that is
but who did that on the floor maybe I'd
go outside
nope what about the bathroom
I hope it's the bathroom ah it is the
bathroom
[Music]
did someone poop that out
did someone swallow that key and then
poop it out and then I grabbed it right
out of the toilet because that's that's
exactly what I want
how badly I want the ball fit
ah I'm a kid I know how to do this I
have the power
[Applause]
yep
I didn't wash my hands I'm gonna pee in
the tube
I'm in
as far as I know I'm gonna eat that
I can't get out
oh I'm still alive maybe or I'm in hell
flashlight this must have been a toy
from that Happy Meal I mean oddly enough
that's a pretty practical toy I'm not
gonna
not gonna besmirch that if that's even
the right word which I'm getting
confirmation that it might not be
okay
okay
uh-huh
any more toilets I can fish keys out of
to progress
I love to progress
Yep this is as my memories serve me from
whence I was a child we all know this is
what the ball pits were like hello
yup is it a jumping puzzle
it's well it's not really a puzzle it's
a it's a jumping
uh I failed the puzzle I'm too stupid to
do it
that's not nearly enough poop on this I
don't know if I'm supposed to take it if
it's not going to be horrible for my
health
all right you convinced me but you shut
up and never tell anybody about this I
love you what did that do for me Isaac
all right back there there was a door
there's a door for a key and I have a
thing for the hole in the key in the the
keyhole the hole I'm gonna put my key in
this hole
I'm smart
well that was convenient is that all I
needed to do
and also what did that do
and what am I supposed to do
I gotta admit if I went into a ball bed
and I had to do this I wouldn't be that
upset I really I really wouldn't you
know because honestly this is a fun time
and better than the
the nightmares of sitting up in the top
of the ball pit and never knowing how
you're going to get out and losing your
family and they're never going to find
you and you're just gonna die in the
ball pit so this is pretty accurate to
what that was
the experience
oh well hmm
oh release him
and I think I see a watermark on this
door but oh well
hey him hey come on out it's good
[Music]
um never mind stay in it don't go away I
hate you
all right I'm out of here
definitely turning my back on that and
whatever it is is whatever
hey hey
whoa
hey okay man I don't know how I survived
that but I did usually I died of things
such as that thing
but okay
I'm jumping I'm crouching I'm jumping
oh
my body has been dumped it stinks so bad
in here yeah you would know
oh yeah you know
fishing Key
turlitz
you
shut up you shut up with your stink oh
seems weirdly blooped
I did it what did I do
what did I do
what did I do
what did I do
what did I do
I guess it opened the wall
all right oh ah another jumping well I
got a run
a run just Rising
Rising I hope it's goop
better be goop it's not it might be oh
no I fell
the game over is it gonna send me all
the way back to the beginning
oh you're kidding me oh okay I'm going
back oh my God it's my fault I guess I
don't know what I did wrong but I know I
did wrong so that's all the matter it's
surprisingly hard to gauge the jumps
it's not about the distance it's about
timing it before you start to slope off
down the front like that see I press the
jump but it doesn't jump because you got
to jump before so you gotta jump way in
advance because else wise you'll start
slipping and there's no guarantee that I
won't do it again I'm almost back there
and I'm definitely not gonna fail
definitely not
definitely not here I go not failing
just gotta jump way ahead of time
seems like I gotta jump
later well all right then almost beefed
it almost did but I didn't but I didn't
oh but I didn't but I didn't but I
didn't but I didn't but I didn't but I
didn't but it didn't
I did well shockingly well
well time for my freedom
well this doesn't look like freedom
I'm gonna get do I actually get it now
please pretty please oh boy oh boy looks
like I must find a key oh
last problem all right I'll find a key
to open this oh I hope it's in some poop
that's the only way I'd ever be able to
recognize it
uh where am I is there a key here how do
I get back whoa
ah I hear ah
okay so it's not a go in four rooms type
is oh it's a key
a key
what was that what was what what's that
what was that what was that
I bet I knew it I knew it was for that
one I knew it wasn't gonna be for the
other one I knew it was gonna be for
that one hey a key all right this should
open the gate somehow I know that well
I'm gonna do it
wait uh I don't I didn't actually get to
can I eat these I want to eat them I
don't know well oh
I'm not gonna look behind me
I'm definitely not gonna look behind me
why would I look behind me look behind
me oh there was nothing oh thank
goodness behind me
[Laughter]
I had a sneaking suspicion
made by glupo well
I gotta say it's not the worst horror
game I've ever played and sometimes it
made me spookified and it might have
made you spookified too so don't deny it
if you did don't deny it
we know
we have ways of knowing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]